sie will alles richtig machen um wieder
bei ihrem sohn zu sein jetzt soll ihr
bloß kein neuer fehler passieren sie
möchte unerkannt bleiben denn sie ist
mama ihr kind weiß nicht dass sie im
gefängnis sitzt seit 2009 10 ist sie
hier erst im geschlossenen vollzug jetzt
im offenen in einem gefängnis in
steinhagen wir nennen sie sabrina
offene vollzug ist halt auch einfach die
möglichkeit zu versagen das ist halt
einfach mit tatsache wenn man sich da
nicht bewähren kann dann schafft man es
nicht als chefköchin der gefangenen hat
sie einen eigenen größeren haftraum
können dass mein zimmer sabrina sagt sie
bereut nichts mehr als ihre taten sie
hat anderen und auch sich selbst damit
sehr geschadet
ich hab mich nicht gestellt ich bin nun
festgenommen worden wegen fahren ohne
gültigen war eine gültige fahrerlaubnis
betrug
kreditbetrug und
computerbetrug als sie ins gefängnis kam
da war ihr sohn gerade ein jahr alt ein
halbes jahr vorher als sie erfährt dass
sie die haft antreten soll beschließt
sie mit ihm unterzutauchen zu fliehen
dann kam der brief und dann habe ich
gedacht na dann habe ich in einer
hauruck-aktion sachen gepackt von meinem
kleinen sohn und mehr und
dann sind wir in urlaub gefahren so
nennt sie das ein halbes jahr sind sie
verschwunden auch der vater des kindes
weiß nichts
das war unser urlaub vor laufen gelernt
hat das war der erste zweite tag war
wirklich alleine den weg der lang
gegangen ist in der stadt wo ich dann
noch festgenommen worden bin denn der
vater lässt nach ihr suchen
dann hat uns ein privatdetektiv in
niedersachsen gefunden ich vergessen
niemals dem moment wo ich im
polizeipräsidium drin bleiben musste und
er mit seinem papa zum auto gegangen ist
das werde ich nie im leben vergessen das
war das schlimmste gefühl was ich
gefunden habe ehrlich anfangs im
geschlossenen vollzug darf sie ihm gar
nicht sehen heute weiß sie wie falsch
ihre entscheidungen waren sagt sie jetzt
nicht warum man mit ihm auch flucht aber
es wäre nicht weil ich ihm schaden
wollte sondern einfach weil ich mein
baby nicht alleine lassen wollte ich das
ist schwer zu verstehen nicht weiß das
aber ich glaube als mama ist das ja das
ist beste was ich habe frauen im
gefängnis noch immer kommt dass viel
seltener vor es ist oft charme der sie
davon abhält offen darüber zu reden
weil ich glaube dass er noch gar nicht
versteht was muss ein mensch machen
damit der weg kommt wie will man lassen
kleinkind auch erklären ich habe es
nicht hingekriegt
kinder könnten hier zu besuch kommen
aber sabrina möchte das nicht sie darf
im offenen vollzug das gefängnis
verlassen dann trifft sie ihren sohn ich
sage immer man fährt wieder zur arbeit
mama hat ganz viel arbeit also für ihn
es ist einfach ich fahre wieder zur
arbeit ich bin wie eine montage mama so
erklären dass eine mutter hinter gittern
die weniger dafür da sind dass die
frauen nicht fliehen sondern dass die
männer von außen nicht rein klettern zu
ihren frauen der jva-beamte eschen gerd
kontrolliert das regelmäßig und es ist
nicht die einzige besonderheit wenn
frauen im gefängnis sitzen erklärt er
sie sind emotional so minder sind auch
emotional klar wenn er habe auch meine
kinder zu hause das feld bei den frauen
schon mehr auf so das steigert schon die
emotionen sehr dass die frauen dann
öfters mal traurig sind zu uns kommen
noch ein bisschen mehr redebedarf haben
das vielleicht mehr natur die beamtinnen
und beamten machen hier viel mehr als
tür auf tür zu in sportgruppen geht es
raus zum laufen mit den gefangenen dabei
hören sie häufig von den problemen doch
mitleid haben wäre ein fehler sagen sie
das ist halt bei der schwierigkeit das
aus zu finden manche sind halt
emotionaler und die anderen versuchen
einfach dadurch dass sie halt vielleicht
weder ist spielen wir wie durch ihre art
dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr doch
zu erreichen das passiert auch schon
heuer zusammen laufen gehen zuhörer
haben das klingt nicht nach einer
besonders harten haftzeit
das ist für jemanden der wahrscheinlich
mich hier im vollzug arbeitet immer sehr
schwer zu sehen das war für mich am
anfang auch ein bisschen kompliziert
muss ich zugeben weil man dann denkt hat
es ja alles sehr locker aber das ist
sehr sehr lockere müssen sich die damen
auch erst mal erarbeiten
und wir wollen halt dass die kinder
nicht großartig leiden die kinder sind
ein gesunder im mittelpunkt erst mal
weil wir können ja nun auch nicht
wirklich was dafür dass da irgendwas
passiert ist deshalb unterstützen die
beamtinnen und beamten bei allem was auf
das leben in freiheit vorbereitet
und da geht es dann auch jemandem
vollzugsöffnungen die maßnahmen also
sprich ausgang urlaub irgendwann oder
sowas wie es jetzt der fall ist um
freigang und freies
beschäftigungsverhältnis dass man
außerhalb der jva arbeitet denn sabrina
hat einen job gefunden der arbeitgeber
weiß von ihrer vergangenheit
erstmal habe ich nicht gesagt dann habe
ich lange überlegt auch mit meinem
betreuer gesprochen ob das sinnvoll ist
und ja aber letztendlich ehrlich währt
am längsten und ich habe ja nichts zu
verlieren mehr wie nein kann ich ja
nicht bekommen sie schaut nur noch nach
vorne nutzt auch die freie zeit am
ausgang um sich vorzubereiten
ich wollte einmal zur fahrschule sie
darf raus mit ausgangs schein
noch mein handy holen und dann auch ihr
telefon für ein paar stunden nutzen
sonst ist es hier eingeschlossen
also wird ein handy auf den haftraum
gefunden werden ist es ein
disziplinarverfahren und was das nach
sich zieht das würde bedeuten kein
ausgang keine freiheiten und auch keine
fahrschule mehr die besucht sie zweimal
pro woche um ihren führerschein zu
machen
sabrina versucht sich wieder zurück ins
normale leben zu tasten hofft ende
diesen jahres frühzeitig entlassen zu
werden schon jetzt geht sie in ihren
ausgängen einkaufen und besucht die
familie trotzdem hat sie respekt vor der
freiheit
danke sehr ja bitte
danke tschüss
man ist in seinen ausgang und in seinem
urlaub draußen aber sobald ich das
gebäude wieder betreten habe ich halt
einfach diese sicherheit das ist mein
schutz com ich bin von der außenwelt ja
so ein bisschen abgeschrieben ich krieg
diese ganzen probleme die vielleicht
draußen sind oder auch innerhalb der
familie im freundeskreis gar nicht mit
weil ich einfach gar nicht die
möglichkeit habt dann nach außen zu
kommunizieren
und das ist schon nach der zeit einfach
eine gewohnheit dass es aktuell das
zuhause von einem zuhause hinter gittern
wenn einmal wieder da mein handy ein
sabrina will es schaffen hier wieder
raus für ihren sohn ganz bald